ERA WARNING THE
TAIWAN.UOTE, ITFIIT COMES TO
TENSIONS ARE RISING AFTER
SECRARY OFTATE ANTY  USELF-DEMO
RTN CNN'S D CULLIVER LIVE IN
SHANGHAI WITH MORE.ENT RHETORIC
>> Reporter:N,T'IS POINT.
IT BECOMING TION, MILITARY
ACTION THAWEE STARTING TO HE F E
GOINAL
AND AIR EXERASGRESSIVE.
ENING TO ABOUT 500
MIS T FROMRE HER SHANGHAI.
METHING THAT IS
CAUSING TENSIONS TO RISE
JUS WE
LEARNED THAT CHINESE FIGHTERS
AIR DEFEZO.AIW
MINIST CAUSED T OF UNEASFO THEIE
AND IT'S PUT THE U.S. IN
DI
THEY NOW HAVE TO DETERMINE HOW
TO RPO
CHINA IS ITS MILITARY
MIGHT, RELEASING THROUGH STATE
MEDIA A FL DRAMATIC O
THESE
THEY SHOW CHINESE
EXERCISES THAT U.SMEE TH
PEOPLE OF TAIWAN.T IS A REATO
IINCREASINGLY AGGIVE
BEIJING DIRE AT IW
CHINA
POLICY, THE PEOPLE'SD LING C
PARTY CONSIDER TWAN TO BE PART
OFEREIGN TERRITORY.
XI JINPING TO NEVER ALLOW
BECOMEORMALLY INNDD
HE WILL T RULE OUT THE USESARY E
>> HE'S ALSOO THE
YO HELPING TAIWAN.
>> Reporter: IN RECENT MONTHS,
THOPIBERATION ARMY  SHOASIT TWA.
MILITARY SHA
POIND DE THED
F  SUPPORT.
FROM ABOVE, NEAR DAILY ULTIPL
AIRCFTIW M TH.
A COORDINATED MO T
ALARMING T
IT HAS SPARKEDTRONG WORDS FROM Y
AND WE WILE E
NEED TA WA
>> Reporter:S MILIIS NO COMPARET
BOTHAN 1 MILLION
SOLDIE.
TAIWAN HAS 140,000 TROOPS.
200 NUCLEAR WARHEADS.TAIWAN HAS.
THAT IS WHY THND ILIANT ON ALLI.
>> AND WE HAVE
MAKE SURE TAIWAN
HAS THE ABILITY TO DEN
.
>> Reporte BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS STOPPED
IN MOV TAIWASTEAD, THE U.S. HAS
ITOWN THS.
THIS PHOTOK G UIMISSILE
FICER
SITTING FEET PROPPED UP AS ONE
OFNA AIRCRAFT IE
SAILED BY.
AND WHILE THE PLA HAS ED
THJOHN McCAIS TOS EAST,
TO THEE GUIDIS
ST RMAINLAND AND TAIWAN.AN
IN RESPONSE OFFICIAL
SAID THE U.S. WAS STIRRING UP
TROUBLE.
LEADE
OIWAN CAW.
>> I THINK THREAIS ING THIST X
MY OPS PROBLEM IS
MUCH CLOSER TO US THAN MOST
THINK.
>> Rep
ADMINISTRATION FG MOUNTING
PRRE
TEA RI ANALYSTS BELIEV
OF WHAT WE'RE SE IS
UNNEY HYPE.>> THEEAL ISO
DEY ACHIEVED THAT GOAL.
ANI DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
CHINESE ARE LIKELY TE FORCE
TH NEXT FE
T PAY
THE PRICE.
>> RHA
TER NAVY  INTELLIGENCE OFFICER
CACHINA'S IN DIRECTED TO
>> THEY WANT THEMEN PEOPLE
ERT TO  OF HELPIN
AS EXCEEDING
>> YOUL CAPTAIN,
YOU'LL HAVE AMERICANS WHO WILL
OKT Y SHOULD
ERD IN
YTR THERE?
HAPPENINTH TAIWACARET'S
LD SAY>> IF 70-YEAR
E OR NOT WILLING TCRIFICE ANYTH.
OTHER COUNTRIES IN THE REGION?
>> THIS ESL NDU.S. A
FOR EXAMPLE, ONEE U.S.
E,S  REGULARLY
TO TRY TLIKEWISE RESPOND TO
BOMBERS THAT HAVE ALSO BEE
GOING INTOE AIDE
ZONE.
SOOTF EYESS.
TOWARDS THE POINT OFAT ID LINEC.
AND SO ANYTHING TH